let's do it okay all right ladies and
gentlemen welcome back to your favorite
podcast you know the name all right just
sing a mic to the guest that was good
whatever you got let me see
[Music]
I wanted to throw it back at him
yeah oh you thought we just started oh
yeah little Christina and you're like
please give the mic back
[Music]
[Music]
this favorite Harry Potter sorry I'm
doing a little extra because my voice
has been just [ __ ] up for months I
wonder why no no it's just cuz I had
like I had a sinus thing and yeah and
then like that's why I got this air
purifier going but then I just feel the
gold in this bag so it's like you know
and people notice it because you do it
every week and people are like oh
something's wrong with Griffin's bullies
you know but here we are ladies and
gentlemen welcome to the podcast
longtime friend of mine we did a great
sketch together a call what was it
called again
being a Josh that was funny regular at
The Comedy Store from a entertainment
from snapchat but you know what though
more importantly my friend mr. Justin
Martindale oh hello everyone thank you
you're here honey we did it I know I
said you were like busy uh bitching
people out on your phone it's what I do
best
so you so you do you do you do you find
yourself having to attack controls I
don't know it's not the trolls I just
you have a lot of pet peeves I have a
lot of Pepe's I have a lot of Pepe's I
have a lot of pet peeves with people who
think they're they're something that
they're not so that's so real and I just
call I just call [ __ ] on a lot of
[ __ ] so I do so wiki you were in mid
calling [ __ ] out what happened well
no it's just I was telling you one of my
biggest pet peeves right now is when it
happened a long time well I think it
still happens in comedy clubs were you
know you'll see somebody you've never
seen before and or like you'll see
something online they're like I'm a
regular at The Comedy Store and you're
like are you and and then they'll post
something and then like you'll go check
that person out on Instagram or whatever
and it says comic and the bio and you're
like hmm and then you actually see them
do something and it's not funny at all
and you're just like oh you know I used
to keep man like I remember this is
I experienced this when I did like you
know you do these like out-of-town shows
like like say how are out of LA or I
went to hem it oh I know Hemet yeah I
went to heaven doing this weird show the
check bounced on that show bottle oh
yeah it's Hemet yeah and so in a guy and
so the guy was asking the comic store
credits and this one person was like you
know regular at The Comedy Store and I
looked at how I said I've never seen you
before yeah we all know each other yeah
yeah yeah whoo you know what it was is
they had done like a bringer show in the
in the main room one of Argus and
Cathy's bringer shows and maybe they've
done it a couple times so yeah you have
regularly performed in the building yeah
but to say you're our regular is like yo
and only because I take offenses all the
[ __ ] we had to do to become a regular
yeah although all the rigmarole and then
you're just gonna say it I mean this is
like back in the day when myspace was
out and then like you know you had a
comedians profile yeah is if you put it
on the internet it makes it legitimate
yeah god yeah so that's that's where I'm
at where I'm just like well because I
have a show coming out on an MA in March
March 11th it's called that we actually
started at The Comedy Store called it
was called stand up to the streets it
was and then he took it and they called
it the marketing department all got
together and brainstormed like
throughout the night and they came up
with the funny dance show yeah so get
ready
March 11th only on E that's the day
before my birthday yeah oh yeah the 12th
yeah I'm the 20th um so are you deep
like you you like being on either all
right are you like a e person or what
what did you like are you where you
would like to be right now like you know
when you first got into come because I
know you had a great story of how you
got past oh yeah that's why a lot of
people hated you for a long time no it
was just some random and she was there a
performance she came down from the
mountain like one night I remember that
day at the college - we all were and
everybody was talking about it like you
[ __ ] he just passed him you know
everybody's like what people are so
pissed yeah so mad at me so mad um yeah
I'm a little by the way I'm little
jealous of your Joe Rogan experience mug
I've been on this [ __ ] show and I
didn't get any merch what the hell is
going on here with this I just texted
his ass like no you did yes I did I was
a yo where's my service you just gonna
just floss it too late oh hi click but
yes you got past like that so anyways at
the point did you always want to be a
comic like what point did like was that
like a dream come true or is it just
still like a whirlwind of like to where
you are now like run me through it well
I mean like back then it was just I was
just trying to get by it was just um
because I mean it was a different was
like the recession was happening in an
in LA so it was just like everybody was
broke and I was like 2008 ish 2008 yeah
sure so it was just something that it
was like oh we'll give you you know a
sandwich you know you're like man and so
yeah it was just you know people weren't
people were went out on auditions and
stuff like that it was just like what's
the point yeah and I was still waiting
tables at the time and it was like I'd
show up and there'd be locks on the door
because they couldn't pay us and we'd
have to go to like a um to go cash our
checks it like a check cash place oh
yeah check cashing cashing places and
they would balance and they'd take
interest oh yeah and and yeah and then
finally it was just like I just remember
seeing some like lame-ass like stand-up
thing on TV and I was like these people
suck I was like I could do this I don't
even remember who was on and it was just
like it was like on logo or something I
was like oh what was logo and it was
like when we were Paul started RuPaul's
Drag Race so they did like some like
LGBT like comedy thing and I was like oh
god right is this what it is I'm like I
could blow this [ __ ] out of the water
and I called up a friend and was just
like hey I want to try it out and I got
like six minutes at this place that
still does a comedy night on Tuesday
call them drunk onstage it's great /
Akbar and I have been and and did it and
then every month that was October 2008
and so every month I did like a monthly
show I got on some like monthly show
Tammy Jo Darrin was doing shows around
town and then I think like Kathy Lewis
was the one who was like hey I've got
that open mic night and I was like oh
let's try it out and then it was packed
Michael Jackson just died and everyone
was there that night I think was like a
Friday night cuz everybody was there and
yeah and I guess admits he came down
from the castle and saw me on stage and
was like man yeah you just and that was
it and it doesn't happen like never yeah
so like I said technically it's don't
yeah I'm the last one the last one that
was chosen by her personally um I see mm
that was 2009 June 2009 she found some 9
yeah Wow
yeah and then I had no I had no idea
what it was like what what does that
mean they're like you get past I'm like
okay yeah see that's what's wrong I had
no clue I saw you - Mike I was like Brad
who I was Davison character was like
that's funny and then so like you said
you're watching logo I mean it's like
obviously I mean we don't have to talk
about you being gay but stuff but like I
understand that when you like people
people like to label so it's like yes it
is you're not just a comic you're like a
black calm yes a lesbian comic gay comic
an alternative comic a mainstream comic
you know a Jewish car so you get that
label of gay comic and it's fury it
doesn't fury it yeah but yeah band
because also like I feel like people get
pigeonholed into performing a certain
way it's same way like black comic like
it's only like if you go to a black show
it's like a lot you feel like oh this is
very black like you feel it you know
what's going on here but no because I've
been I've been in both environments like
chanson
you know man when I first started it was
crazy cuz you know I mixed race and so
it's like I go off and do it ladies do
it you know I mean but it's like it's
still like I would go to these like
biggety biggety black shows would be
like like oh [ __ ] this is like I didn't
know was gonna be like this and but then
like okay so then you're like you're a
gay you're gay if you don't consider
some of a gay comic but then everything
you see like especially if you're
looking at at that time you're looking
at logo like they didn't want somebody
up there talking normal yeah talk about
normal stuff just like you know when you
go to the DMV no I ain't wanted to be
like you know when you're gay and the
doors open and you walk in and you're
like oh man yeah okay does that what
inspired is have you always tried to go
against that um what I started I did
yeah
because I was afraid I was afraid I was
gonna get like you know not appreciate
it I guess like people were gonna be
like oh that's the CVS funny yeah well
what don't see me as gay I don't want to
see like well I'm straight okay cool
yeah yeah yeah I'm you know and it
always kind of like it weirded me out
when you saw somebody you know who who
was Asian and they'd get up on stage and
they're like so I'm Asian and you're
like oh is that so it just made me kind
of like and and then like as I was
watching gay comics for a while I just
realized it kind of went into that like
real blue material where it was just
like oh I got a shock the [ __ ] out of
him and it just wasn't my style and it
was just real bitter and real like you
know like you know what you're getting a
[ __ ] no I don't it's been months the
Sahara is dry with this desert so I just
kind of was like there's way more I want
to take my perspective on it and show
everybody that it's not so like oh here
we go
you know what I mean but then you also
did but then you find yourself swinging
far the other way
where it's just like you're just trying
to deny you know to me like that drag
but just kind of be like don't what are
you guys talking about don't even
mention that to me but yeah but then
have define yourself now more
comfortable words just like yeah
absolutely no absolutely and I just feel
like it's so I mean he'll we have like a
we have people to judge who's running
for president it's like the first openly
gay like presidential candidate and I'm
just kind of like we know with but in
his name we're but in the same I know
the irony I know I know I know I know I
thought it was beauty check yeah I just
wanted to like just start twerking and
like and Pence is like oh god I'm
getting a boner Bobby yeah i yeah i
think one i want to say like maybe a
couple years ago i mean it's only been
I've been I've been doing been a paid
regular there for about ten years now
and I want to say like in the past like
three four years is when I started kind
of loosening up and just being like I
mean I know what I sound like I was
gonna say like there's no yeah so I mean
it's just it's just it's just I'm
finally comfortable in my own body and
I'm comfortable I've always been
comfortable my own body but it's just
uncomfortable in if you're gonna be let
you okay take care yeah if you don't
like me you clearly have something wrong
with you you know or or if that's like
the issue like I don't know like eat
even last Saturday I don't know if you
heard about this so last Saturday at the
store we were in the the original room
and the door guy Alex Alex yes I walk in
at like 8:15 or something and he was the
door guy who went up at like 7:25 to
warm everybody up okay got you and
apparently there was this bachelor party
of like 15 guys there oh yeah so I've
already like and they were already like
a little drunk or whatever and I guess
he got up on stage and that's one of the
guys out of nowhere was just like get
off the stage you suck you [ __ ]
[ __ ] at like 7:30
that man started strong at 7:30 and then
you know the entire room is like the
butthole just what and I I walked in i
was like yeah how are they nice like
they're really weird I'm like okay well
you know it's Saturday said that well
it'll be more specific then he told me
yeah okay I went in there and I sat down
and there was like a lot of hustle
because they didn't know whether they
were gonna kick him out or not cuz it
was 15 people right and so they were
like okay and they were online yeah and
they don't want to make it even more
awkward like gotten them leave and make
a scene or whatever so I'm sitting in
the back and then Jen comes over and
she's like oh we got security I know
it's like I've got this I'm not what you
know this isn't your first rodeo right
first time you've been like yeah coming
at you yeah
so I get up on stage they bring me up on
stage and Jeff the piano player who's
gay as well he's just like mad he's
angry it's like he's playing cabaret for
no reason Born This Way is [ __ ] and so I
get up on stage and you know and Candace
Thompson was she brought me up and she
was like oh just get ready cuz they're
[ __ ] weird oh my god so I get up on
stage and I was like so I heard you guys
were looking for a [ __ ] [ __ ] and
the room is like and then I I start
talking to them I was like no you don't
do that [ __ ] in my house bro and it was
like he was like oh yeah haha and they
start talking I'm like okay calm down
Bakersfield look you know you're in
cargo shorts and Crocs know and you're
at a bachelor party to comedy club yeah
and it got to the point where like I
finally got everybody back and I set the
room back and I was like did you hear
all that laughter guys
ago who's the [ __ ] now oh it was
liberal Hollywood was like queen
that's what's so funny like lights out
like when we did lights out together I
got a lot of that those comments of
people being like oh another Lib another
liberal where there's a just like I'm
sorry if I'm open-minded I'm sorry if I
don't want the world to catch on fire
you know it's weird because I always
think that like you know we love to
label people and put people in like
general categories you know I mean but
it's like you know it's um I should have
turned my thing off now was that a phone
ring yes a phone ring sorry it's like
you look this I'm doing this by myself
guys and it's hard to like you know it's
hard to turn your phone off yeah you
know what I actually got to keep this on
so I could turn to turn the phone off
well hit the sound post yeah doesn't
even matter just but people know my
ghetto ass podcast you know I mean I'm
gonna put this here so I could just stop
it when it does it again because you
know it's so annoying but like by the
way the floor is covered in crickets and
roaches people already know what the
wires nothing is funky like we love to
put people in boxes and act like that
that they have if anybody else is like
you that you all you have the same
experience you know so the boxes start
with like the one big box would be human
being okay mm-hmm so we're all human
beings you know well I guess the box
before that would be earthlings
I don't think so everything back that's
everything on the planet right right
right and then you go to human being as
if as if we're all the same but we're
not then you go male female yeah we're
not especially like and and that's I
think why there's so much turmoil all
the time it's like females you know it's
like I remember watching like this I
forgot who the the the the pop singer
young actress singer who was on the view
uh-huh she wasn't on the view but she
would they were talking about her
because her phone
hacked and her nudes came out and
they'll and then the ladies on the view
are going like this is why you don't do
that and I'm thinking to myself yo old
chicks like you're at a stage in your
life where you don't want to be naked on
the internet or in real life or in real
life right I get it
but don't the 25 and under girl who
loves her body loves the attention who
you know just who wants to be sexy and
empowered without men being perverts but
that's what it comes with but they still
don't mind because they can deal with it
and they don't mind having their titties
out and they don't mind being sexy
you're not the same dude it's not catch
all female right right people are
different walks of life so you have
these young girls who were like that
then you had the mid-thirties girls who
like it even they aren't all the same
but they have a different experience you
know but also you have the guys too
I get it I get it I get it all the time
so what I'm saying for you it's the same
kind of thing so it's like so now you're
gay you're a comment so it means you
have to be gay you have to be liberal
that means you're like you know you're
anti whatever and you know and it's like
you just catch all box and say how do
you deal with that I just do I'm just /
that's just how I am
I believe in I believe in equality for
everybody I believe if you know it just
blows my mind how it's like you know
we're still in a world where like
females are getting paid less than men
for doing the right like the amount of
work the only thing I did have a problem
with was you know the whole like there
were no female directors nominated for
the Oscars and I'm like that's where we
have to kind of we kinda have to draw
the line there because it's like maybe
they weren't good you know like that's
where I'm just kind of like oh like I
just don't want that's the I don't want
everyone that's the thing we don't want
we're just passing out trophies now you
know it takes away from you the work and
the work is good I do think roediger we
should have been nominated that's for
sure but then like Natalie Portman was
like these are all the names of the
women who were nominated I'm like [ __ ]
you've only worked with like two female
directors your entire career yeah relax
yeah you're a high and it's not on your
production company yeah well don't even
get me started the hypocrisy but yeah
the thing I'll say to that though is
that that's why it needs to start in the
development stage mm-hmm so so it's just
a two-fold problem so you're saying like
hey the FEMA directors that are
currently working do better work yeah
okay agreed but at the same time though
work they're trying to say in the
production phase let's just hire more
females right and then we can have more
to choose from right for Best Director
my solution is if you have Best Actor or
female that's at Best Supporting Actor
female male and do the same thing for
director yeah then you don't have to
worry about it because it's like if I
like Best Actor male best best director
male best director theme yeah why not
you know but then people are gonna be
like we're already you know but it's
like then why do we do you know why we
have to do that imagine if they took
away best male best female actor yeah
this [ __ ] would be bananas because you'd
go who you gonna take away who's not
gonna make it who gave the actual best
performance my whole point about it is
sometimes it's gonna be all white guys
that's the thing and you know sometimes
sometimes it happens and and I just
think no matter what people will find a
way to be outraged and that's so like
the Shakira and JLo performance I
thought it was great
delicious there was they've been fined
by the FCC 1,500 times like there's 1500
cases I like for the FCC again and I'm
like what yeah but then you know maroon
5 came take his shirt off and you know
everyone was pissed off with Janet still
to this day and you know Million Moms or
whatever which was only like a couple
hundred they calm down millions of moms
there's not a million of moms um you
know they're like I'm trying to watch
this halftime show with my children I'm
like hey if they're if you're think
they're gonna get offended by a Latina
woman uh-huh dancing turn the TV off
it's every everyone everyone's outraged
play devil's advocate YES on this the
Super Bowl is if you're a parent you
know there's very few things that you
could sit down with your kids and know
for sure there
nothing inappropriate that's gonna
happen very few things on television
that's like it has to be labeled you
know warning wait wait you know you have
to know so when you're watching a
sporting event you would like to think
that you don't have to explain
sexy movements to your children you
don't because they're already learning
about it on their phones I know that's
the thing they're all on snapchat they
all have their own with you I'm just
yeah just posing another I'm just
pulling the more argument I was more
offended by the game itself what is this
trash on my television that was a great
game I know what you saying man it's
like it's like you know you know it's
like you said like someone like Natalie
Portman are they they they they you they
make this big stink about everything but
it's like it's so hard do I think that
the the liberal elite the rich liberals
and and I'm not rich but I count myself
as like you know a self-hating liberal
because when you start making money and
you start it's hard to relate to people
who are like struggling and trying to
like you know the blue-collar liberals I
wonder like we want this we want that
because like it's all hypocrisy when
you're making money you're a hypocrite
you're a liberal hypocrite you know it's
like coming out about the wall but you
live in a gated community listen I let
you into my wine cave one time alright
and you were not supposed to bring that
up again right you know it's hard to
like it's hard to like you know and but
they want to scream so loud about like
how they have it it's like you know it's
like you say no but you got a production
company hire women [ __ ] yeah just you
hire women you can't [ __ ] about the
problem and not have women if you
yourself aren't gonna be a part of the
solution shut the [ __ ] up yeah you know
alright how about this one too like you
see this whole thing about the birds of
prey movie what about I saw it I saw the
movie okay so but there's a there's a
whole thing about like men don't want to
see strong women and that's why I didn't
do well but when you look at the
statistics more men saw the movie than
women okay so if 54% of the people that
watch that movie are men we ain't a
problem yeah okay like it just sucked
well and also it was it was the DC
it was the Suicide Squad yeah and that
movie tanked right so this was like it
was still in that Suicide Squad universe
yeah so we had just seen
Joaquin Phoenix play the Joker but she
was the Harley Quinn from the Jared Leto
yeah universe of Joker so I think that's
where people were like I would that
Joker wouldn't date this like I want to
see the Joaquin Phoenix Harley Quinn
right already rad like you know and
she's just like so far hard to make that
movie yeah so what I'm saying is like
it's like good for you you hire all
women it's like like you see these women
they act like like most men we're gonna
go to the theater be like no we just
want to see for me I'm just speaking for
me I just want to see a good movie
uh-huh so like when it's not a good
movie I don't want to hear somebody say
oh you didn't like it because it was all
women no no don't speak for me yeah I
didn't like it could the [ __ ] is that
yeah you know one of my favorite
all-female movies was um of the favorite
for sure
did you see that the favorite with
Olivia oh the favorites so good so good
that movie was yeah excellent I loved it
didn't think one time about oh my god
there's so many women in this only women
are talking yeah it was great and the
lesbian league of their own leaked up
their own just just sent one of the best
sports movie hands down so it's like
every time I hear this used to be my
playground oh yeah I'm getting choked up
think about it right now yeah I know it
is hard so then so then getting it back
to you it's like so you have like so now
it's like you have to support Buddha
check that's how people were gonna come
at you and be like well I mean you you
have to I support the efforts give me -
I think it's great I think I think I
think personally I think he's I love his
background I love his history I love his
his his service yeah I think he's done
more than the current guy has and the
only thing is I just think he's just a
little too young he just needs a little
more salt pepper in his hair or a juice
he just I mean and that's the thing is
like you don't want to twink in office
[Laughter]
bringing power back to the people and
the bottoms you know I didn't know that
he was gasps I'm on Bill Maher show and
I was like this guy's great yeah I was
like I was like wow he was like he's
quick-witted and he's like yeah and he's
like you know he knows what to say and
he has things to say about Bernie he's
got thing to say about by saying he's
like all right boom boom and then later
I was like he's gay and I was like oh I
don't know if you go you go are we ready
I don't know what's the same thing we
asked about Obama right I know it's like
ready for a black president apparently
we were yeah but I don't know if there's
any groundswell it's like but I don't
know if we're ready for it old you to be
President either you know that I'm ready
for anything that other than what we
have Missy that's the thing that's so
weird about it after he's gonna go we
had this crazy you know this one
situation he's just outside the box I'm
not gonna give my opinion either way I'm
Jack is out of the box he's out he's
outside the box right and then the
people going up against him it's like
here this old Jewish you know socialist
with the gay the young gay do ya who's
who's got a husband and you got this
like a woman and you got the pervert a
sniffer
yeah we have the Suicide Squad
it's a Suicide Squad for the Democratic
candidate so it's like who knows what's
gonna happen it's so bizarre like I even
said I was like if people judge wants my
vote he needs to like like tag a line
just to [ __ ] read and then just death
drop and if he does a death drop onstage
like a shablam I'm like all right I
would like to see I would like to see a
debate he would be great in a debate
against Trump mm-hm you know cuz Trump
will be trying hard not to call him a
[ __ ]
but I want to know what is what uh
that's that's interesting what did he
call him he called him you know he gives
nicknames but I heard somebody talk
about Bernie saying they're like
Bernie's got the same kind of like
ground support that say Trump had so it
ain't about it's not about to the facts
or about the issues it's just about
these are a lot of people that like them
you know what I mean so maybe interest
one maybe they're the two old guys I can
go at each other you know I don't
normally talk about politics it's just I
know we kind of went in I know but it's
just it's just it's just it goes into
like what we're talking about like
putting people in a box you know and yes
it sucks that even as I'm saying it in
labeling people it's like you know we
can't help but get past that so that's
like maybe one day we'll be able to just
be like it's Bernie it's this person is
that person without having to think
about the other things about them yeah
you know because even Trump himself he's
the he's the closest to independent
president we've had in a long time if
you really think about it he was really
different type of guy and he hijacked a
Republican Party he just picked one you
yeah all right you guys your mom and be
your mom like a leader like and
everyone's like that's what's just so
weird I don't remember ever having a
president he's like are you gonna be
loyal to me and you're like what this is
some Emperor Palpatine yeah like all he
needs is lightning coming out of his
fingers yes so weird but what I loved is
like having the question this was to
Elizabeth Warren like a couple months
ago maybe where they went after her they
were like if you win you will be the the
first female president she's like yeah
and I'll be the youngest one too oh oh
no she did take my wig off throw it yeah
I thought it was awesome
I'm warning Oval Office who takes a wig
off scratches oh yeah all right tell me
about Korea I just tell you what get my
main message for people is just get out
and vote even if you're if you're Pro
Trump and you're Pro how things are
going and you like it and you think that
he's getting a badge the bad rap go out
and vote and if the people that are like
cuz cuz I just feel like the liberal
side does a lot of yappin no no action
whoo you know register to vote though I
already voted make your butt yeah
exactly make your make your stance and
then we'll see what happens in you know
on the other side yeah I mean that's why
they have them but I've that's what I'm
wondering I'm like do we vote never ones
like oh we went blue up at the electoral
college okay that'll chestnut yeah so
we'll see what shows all right let's get
off that [ __ ] all right oh you know
what we should talk about is something
that we both love very much it is the
show the servant which I talked about oh
yeah I talk about a lot on this show
because I love I love this up with other
people you know you do yeah I finished
it yes what did you think yeah if you're
off of it now I can tell I can tell you
how well you know that you have a little
stink eye about it now it disappointed
you
it was confused I liked the last I cuz
cuz I cuz there was a time where when it
was on you and I would be in the hallway
oh yeah like shut up hilarious sketch we
want to say the bad thing to each other
but we don't I liked it I thought the it
was I was waiting for that Shyamalan
twist and it never happened to me was
gonna have two seasons I know there's no
other season coming yes yes because
because even like does everyone know
does everyone know the show yeah this is
so disturbing assembling shambhala show
on Apple TV hosts only like 17 people
are watching it
it was good yeah and it's just some very
weird show with weird angles shots and
like you know this like girl is a nanny
well first of all this is not giving
anything away there's a couple there
baby dies mysteriously the mom has a
psychotic break and they give her a doll
and she thinks this doll is real like a
service dog service dog help her yeah
yeah but she's making it out that this
doll is real yeah she even hires a nanny
The Nanny comes and the nanny's doing
the same thing the husband's freaked out
by that next thing you know a real
baby's in the crib yeah okay and you're
like is this picture which did she make
the bait you know and so then it's just
like well every episode is like a a
weird ending where there's an it's an
open-ended ending and you then used to
watch the next episode to find out what
the [ __ ] happened there and there's like
a the husband's like a chef so there's a
lot of weird culinary like like meats
like he's making weird dishes on the
show that's weird that he has the best
wine cellar ever yeah oh and then her
and then her family shows up they're
weird
yeah she's weird she's beating ourselves
she's like weirdly sexual but they're
not yeah then you just hang in like
straw like artifacts over the Reimann
stuff that Ron Weasley's in it
what Weasley he's great though but no I
mean that's what kind of broke my heart
was the when you find out how the baby
died you're like oh no I [ __ ] you guys
you gotta you should have watched it
already but but then you know what you
know what I needed that I know why
because I needed to know she be that
crazy that she don't know this baby's
not a real baby cuz she had been living
with a dead baby for so long that you
know that she left in the car
it just is tragic it but it was great so
I want to see like what this is but is
the second season gonna be about this
cult you know that's like is there magic
yeah whole thing is so bizarre are they
dead yeah cuz there was a fire where
there's the fire and then taking
somebody's identity cuz then at the end
you see her like walk out of the house
wait hold on let me go back oh is that
what happened they had the big party
having the Chrisman then invited me over
he had placenta balls oh she put heat
this [ __ ] put his wife splice
placenta and in the hors d'oeuvres it
didn't tell nobody no one nobody it just
makes you like you gonna go to people's
party and you don't want to be [ __ ]
right cochlea as you shouldn't trust no
[ __ ] don't trust a [ __ ] that
from Selena trust no [ __ ] but what
happened wait so the baby was there and
then she left and then the baby became a
doll again no no that baby didn't become
a no no okay
remember she see she wanted to know what
really happened to the baby the real
baby so she switched out the doll again
and the baby was someplace else and of
that episode of rubric rents like all
right where the [ __ ] display he was
babysitting yeah yeah coming back you
know and on the party and then at the
end the baby's back and then rubric
Craig comes in he goes she knows and in
the next episode they reveal how it
happened so but but that's what I kept
you gripped every single episode it kept
you like I gotta get more information I
got to get more information but then the
christening was when like they had
they're like oh the baby yay and then
she was left with the doll again it's
because I think that the girl it's her
baby
I think it's her baby you know and then
but then there's like a cult leader I'm
yeah and then she stepped outside and
all those people were there and then the
cop went back and they were gone I be
scattered which would be a good scene to
see yeah you saw I don't know but just
serving is just one of those shows that
I really enjoy so what is it what else
so you watch it like what are you like
cuz you seem like a person that gets
into a show then you're just like this
is that the only one cuz it's very few
of those now that I loved um well I like
horror and suspense that's like my like
what's what you call it with was too big
a producer he made Glee American Horror
Story
you don't like American Horror Story I
you know what you know what you know
what I'm every other season with that
you see oh this is good and then the
next season I might with the [ __ ] yes
see they lost me at Hotel like Hotel was
the one that I was like oh you know like
that one with gaga yeah I liked Hotel it
was weird there was one it's like the
coven I like the coven was [ __ ] that was
the best one I was the best and then
they started getting weird with like
with a Blair Witch to the foul Roanoke
Oh throwing up and then they did I
haven't haven't watched it I haven't
watched since coven I started at the
hotel they did what were they did
apocalypse which was stupid it's just
getting really campy and then the last
season where they did 1985 was trash
trash trash trash it was garbage
no it was so [ __ ] lame it was so lame
and I'm getting on Twitter if you like
this is the best one yet I'm like you're
a ghoul and then now they just released
the cast for the new season which is
they don't have a title yet did they get
rid of everybody finally and they got
new people and Emma Roberts is not on it
um Sarah Paulsen's back oh I think I
think they lady the older lady I forget
her Jessica laughs Jessica Lange is she
I don't know yeah I think Kathy Bates
might be back and Evan Peters as well
but here we go
the new addition to the cast okay
Macaulay Culkin really oh yeah I love
makovica and if it's called American
Horror Story home alone amen
oh that would be like his I like his
after her I like his adult career I know
the weird things he's done and like you
know like you know he's get this because
his bad I love his brother too if you
watch I do you watch succession no
that's the way I need to get into I know
I know [ __ ] I know that show is my watch
again [ __ ] cuz now like we're different
universes right now there's the
you've watched the show or you haven't
watched a show universe okay I'm gonna
watch it oh wow that's a good one man
I'm really excited about Westworld yup
no you're gonna get into it
you know [ __ ] the new season of Westar
listen first of all I'm not with yuk-yuk
you want to talk about transit I'm not
with emo emo terminator okay
I'm not with it just reset the hard
drive [ __ ] you know you go into a place
where you want to live out your
fantasies ah
and then these [ __ ] are can
feel [ __ ] now we're now we're monsters
now once again it's like avatar human
beings are terrible I know it looks kind
of cool cos they get her like the real
world and that's what I'm kind of down
for and then I remember watching that
first season and being like who cleans
up the calm like that is self-cleaning
is who's the flesh like their butthole
or something yeah you lick your Apple
watch when you said it I can't wait it's
gonna be there's some good TV shows
coming out soon I think like what well I
need to watch love is blind because
everyone's losing their [ __ ] on that
which one is that see I know the Netflix
one where they they have it oh no no no
yes yes so they have people in pods I
guess it's like in a soundstage and they
get to know the person only from their
voice oh yeah that's not gonna work
you don't think so because then they get
to propose and get married and
apparently it's like a huge [ __ ] short
of course it's a [ __ ] show of course of
course she loves hearing she's just like
she's like that [ __ ] is not going to
work no but I'm not a bachelor person I
can't watch The Bachelor I can't watch
the Housewives I'm like yeah any time I
watch the shows about women being
ratchet you know oh I'll watch I'll
watch what's it called the the
basketball basketball Why ask of all
wives have you seen love at hip-hop and
I've seen some yeah listen white girls
act and ratchet is one thing I mean it's
like I look I don't like those shows but
I like to recap show of those shows oh
yes we have them on the stage like I
want to be a moderator or the recap show
of those things is just to be like you
know do you ever watch a big brother
uh I have yeah I love
brother my friend Holly was on the last
season Oh Holly Holly was a place with
the with the guy that she's dating now
oh that's good yeah see I wish they
would do a season accent that's his name
oh yeah yeah yeah I wish they would do a
season of other guy they called racist
which was so I was so infuriated by that
he was no yeah they could yeah they were
calling him an associate anyways but
he's from Tennessee
I would like to don't put people in a
bar
I'm not putting people in a by anyway
this is what I want to see for Big
Brother I would love to see a season of
the people that were on Big Brother
watching Big Brother okay so I want to
see I want to see them watching
themselves and then have moments of like
like I want to be the moderate where I
go pause so right there you were you
said you were lying about what do you
what do you feel about that or like
people be like do you see how stupid you
look right here you look really dumb
here how do you feel about that if that
would be to me fascinating to see them
watch themselves and be like wow I
really am a [ __ ] idiot or oh yeah
malaya yeah [ __ ] because I'm trying
to win 5,000 not whatever I just
actually there'll be interest but isn't
that also just production where don't
you think like the producers oh I know
for a fact cuz since tonight is the
premiere of season 12 of RuPaul's Drag
Race oh Jesus oh yeah [ __ ] Kevin Kristy
and I go in it's like it's different TV
universes it's like our it's our uh it's
our fantasy football I know Leslie Jones
loves she is she gonna be on it yes
she's on it this season as a guest judge
Wow but she's also like damn you know
didn't tell me about season three and
I'm like girl season 12
it's just so funny cuz she'll be like
Raj is a [ __ ] and I'm like Raja [ __ ]
wins and that's my friend so I got a lot
of drag for you so what happens with the
producers well they you know they'll
tell them like you know let's set up a
alright you know like okay so and so
gave you a weird look
how does that make you feel you have to
push this yeah but when you want to see
the thing about Big Brother is you hear
you know they when you watch the 24-hour
feeds nothing and stuff you hear the
producers say in life you know just then
go to the room you know just to put your
mic on it's really like a weird cuz I
don't watch the fees but I watched a big
brother after dark and it's a completely
they're like [ __ ] and stuff no they
know I don't do they don't show that
stuff but there has to be tapes
someplace I've seen some um you've got
videos it's gotta be outtakes of a Big
Brother where people are having sex
there's a video of one of the guys from
like Big Brother somewhere no no I don't
know if it was American even oh he's
just jerking off in the shower jerking
off and he's trying to be so cautious
about it because he knows he's being
filmed but he's just got a pump and
release he and he's he's he's leaning
over and he's you know obviously in the
shower the shower stall the irony is
just like and you see this muscle moving
you know this is not you know you're not
loo fleeing sir like how much are you
scrubbing your walls right but I was
like damn I mean what you're in a you're
in a house for like 90 days well
apparently there's a lot of sex going on
- its to be there has to be not for
everyone cause II always have see my
problem with me my problem with big
brother is this whole like you know this
diversity push mm-hmm I don't give a
[ __ ] about diversity on a show like that
well that's everywhere now they're like
we need it diverse so but I want 20 hot
in shape athletic people being awful to
each other okay
I don't you need real world versus road
rolls thank you yes that's what I want
when I watch TV I want to watch regular
[ __ ] I'll go to the DMV and
watch them fight okay
but I don't meet when I'm watching my TV
show I don't need the nerd chick I don't
need the fat guy I don't need the fat
girl I don't need to do who like you
know the shut-in I don't need like you
know [ __ ] these people okay I don't want
to see them on a on a reality show where
the the essence of the show is to bring
out the worst in people's personality
because that's what a big brother is it
brings out the worst
because they have to lie and cheat
because they're trying to win $500,000
get that [ __ ] nerd out of there that
can't [ __ ] climb up a rock get that
bill get out okay I've been a service
engineer for five years I want to see
pretty as you know tits ass abs be a
terrible dong yeah being terrible and
then they do because that's escapism and
then we can like be like okay you
survived all that anytime there's always
some kind of false push of diversity
yeah I'm just like look what you're
doing it's good to get back to our
previous conversation it's like the
Oscars man it's like what do you want
you have to ask yourself out there do
you want the best people the best
performances the best productions to win
or do you want to see diversity yeah cuz
they're not always the same yeah that's
why I gave up on Survivor I was just
like this is watched it's just too
staged but I will watch naked and afraid
cuz that [ __ ] naked and afraid
is my Jail oh yeah could this is like
what are you doing honey what are you
doing
I think you know what I love about
making it afraid like they okay first of
all and you've never seen naked and
afraid it's like these survivalists type
yeah and they think they could survive
in like the Amazon jungle Ilia take a
spot and they drop them off there and
they're supposed to survive for like
what is it like 24 24 days something
like that they have no Huey's there's no
water they have to survive I love
watching at the end and they show them
like six weeks later like somebody's
face is still swollen
everybody's so be the bug and the
disease that they got there for the
south is it worth it I mean I think so I
mean but then again you know I can
barely go east of La Brea you know it's
that's that's my survival turn out I'm
like no like I get to that target on the
corner but that's what's so amazing
though it's like you have to you meet a
you meet a complete stranger who's
apparently just as good as you are
ryuuji a male and a female male and a
female your butt ass naked I want to see
two gay guys are they gonna [ __ ] you
lesbians are they gonna scissor no
because at
after day - they haven't showered true I
think gays are out yeah you already
start losing weight you hangry already
and that extra skin just falling off
yeah it's just that shows are you do
they give you toilet paper no you're
using leave that's one of those things
they just never like it's like on will
you talk about like on West world dizzy
they don't show you the scene we're on
the covers coming out I'm making it
afraid they don't show you like that's
what you want to see the outtakes of
somebody yeah by a tree you want to see
Big Brother watching Big Brother I want
to see people I want to see a woman
sitting on a patch of moss during her
period just picked the wrong time of the
month to do naked and afraid like gross
or like the guy waking up with just a
boner and they're trying to keep warm in
the night and she's like oh yeah I saw
one where the first thing they do for
the females is they go make a bra and
panties
oh right have you never seen that I
haven't seen the woman I'm hey that's
cheating well but they have to make it
they this week I saw the guy like me the
phone where they have the palm fronds
like that you see me like a little hole
you know but I just was like you see
them they're all bitten up I just want
to see the producer come over and be
like well I always think I don't I don't
think in that show there's a camera crew
there it's just one dude see I would be
upset because it just gotta be a certain
point where you're like you know you're
looking at the guy with the camera cuz
he's got to have his own water as she
said yeah how you gonna do it
just watching this naked turn he's got
like a beef jerky yeah he's got like his
trail mix [ __ ] are starving I
had to go back to craft services well
the great scene is like to see them all
like you cut this way in there and
managers inflation so yeah frozen on
camera like this is all fake yeah I yeah
they're all bitten up and swollen oh I
stopped watching like like I like those
type of shows and I find myself liking
like 10 episodes you know you know big
fantasy type shits cuz i don't i don't
watch like CSI miami or CSI or NCIS or i
don't even watch new lawn orders or
anything like that i stopped watching
serial television like i watch it at all
yeah right it's just too real yeah it's
just
oh god especially like the one what's
the one with the Special Victims Unit
Oh SVU yes we use always about sex
crimes yeah it's like we're from the
heavy right I'll just read the headline
I don't need to rehash well and I also
get like Twitter updates of like missing
person found dead and you're like wow
cool like no it's just everything's
awful so I like that escapism okay yeah
so you like lock and keys actually kind
of fun I haven't seen that's pretty fun
it's like a kids kind of like yeah I saw
that on TV and king's son wrote it can
you believe how many Netflix shows there
are a lot have you just one day just
been like I'm looking for something -
what cuz I'm gonna Road i watch Netflix
I'm looking I'm sorry let me see what I
want to watch and then it's just like
what the [ __ ] yeah is this yeah there's
a lot this is like and then I get mad -
like why did I go out for this [ __ ] yeah
I had a meeting with Netflix in January
I was like I'm in yeah like I'll host
cornflake War like I'll do some [ __ ]
like they have somebody a pets of
extreme Chia Pets or something they have
a lot of competition reality shows on
Netflix now that are just ridiculous
uh-huh I love nailed it I mean Nicole
Byer and nailed it I just think it's so
funny Oh what's nailed what
nailed it I gotta get the coal buyer yes
she's fantastic she um
so she hosts this show where it's like
you have like an expert cake maker who
makes like fondant and Wow you know
sculptured cakes right it's three randos
right we're like I can bake too but my
kids hate it they bring them on in and
the challenge is for them to make what
is in front of them after watch because
and and it's just so fun I think that's
what I love about it is the passion and
the drive right it's kind of like that
show what was that show wipeout oh yeah
yes and they're like they're like I'm
gonna do that the American Ninja Warrior
the first thing to get hit Wow
gone yes it's why I was obsessed as a
kid watching next on MTV remember it was
like a dating show and they had the buzz
like my name is Jacqueline I'm 16 and
this guy's not gonna know what to do
with me it walks something's like next
and she's like have you seen what still
okay oh you're giving me going now okay
cuz one I love I love I love 90-day
fiance I haven't seen that yet either I
know okay so I have this of [ __ ] like
you know that like you're gonna have to
you couldn't had you on my podcast
I should've gave me homework watch your
show watch succession is my okay and
love is blind
that's the assignments you have to okay
i'ma watch these cuz cuz like not a
fiancé is one of those and then there's
other ones like have you ever seen
marriage house what oh my god is this on
Netflix you know what's on Netflix it
sound like it's like a bra for one of
those oh I always kill them all the same
galbi ground
significant what show Kardashians it's
naughty
that's the other one it's like so that
one they they you know all these couples
come in the house and then they trying
to get married in this house you know
why for why I no [ __ ] clue this
desire like people that fail in
relationships go you know what I can do
mmm let me go on TV and and and go to
some weird format that'll be better for
my relationship yeah you're you're are
you your trainwreck what are you [ __ ]
talking about you can't just you know
you don't mean doesn't make any sense so
there's that one and then there's the
one oh this is my favorite one but I
don't know the [ __ ] of it but like
it's on a beach uh-huh okay and it's
like your ex comes so you're like you
know us on the beach I don't it might
because hey so you're like so that
you're in a house with like hot people
I love Island and then and then you're
then they bring your ex and your ex is
introduced into the house and then like
you know you're gonna say that drama and
then they bring another ex it sounds
like ex on the beach so that's the one
that it's just there should be a network
called train wreck yes
and these shows should be on there
absolutely it just doesn't make any it
doesn't make any sense do you have a do
you have a favorite show moment like
that just sticks in your head like it
could be like reality reality television
oh well what a lot of my favorite show
moments are on the on the recap shows
uh-huh okay but one of my favorites is
on 90 day fiancé
just pretty face fat girl okay that's
listen that's our [ __ ] description if
she was if she was at a liquor store she
was robbing the place at gunpoint and a
cop said what does she look like you'd
be like well she's a PFF G okay anyway
she's in love with this skinny dude in
Morocco who's trying to get his green
card you know we got it she send in all
her money okay so then I just never
forget this two moments in that she goes
to visit him in Morocco and he takes her
on a hike this [ __ ] is a disaster he
goes so he's taking a Moroccan hike but
she goes to Morocco to visit him and
he's taking her on like a mountain
like this fat girl oh and it just it
just was terrible that's not a match
okay that's what I'm saying is that's
not a match they were leave her there
you know she said my moment I remember
she goes I told you I don't work out
that was same couple he's like do you
know how to do the testimonials like
they me and then I could late like he's
off to decide at the airport talking to
the camera and he's all saying like you
know she's very pretty pretty but I
didn't know that she was so big like you
didn't know [ __ ] really like it
it's like I just
it's like those kind of moments these
manufactured like weird and not a did
Fox not any fiance it's full of that
okay I gotta watch it because you have
like you oh my god they have hot couples
on there too that you think are gonna
work but it's still something shady
going on and then you have the couple's
of like here's this fat girl in shape
dude she's he's trying to get his green
card or it's always like old guy old fat
guy young pretty girl you know she's
trying to get a green card it's like
come on
alright I'm and what are you doing Oh
see one of mine that just sticks out in
my head is God warrior from wife swap
why see twice is Gina wife swap was a
hole I remember I remember wife swap do
you ever God warrior no okay for your
listeners out there if you don't know
the story behind God warrior
it was a rotund woman she was living
mall parking by on it easily easily and
by the way how do you get to five
hundred pounds what does she wish you
one of those I can't get out a bit no
but close hey girl name was Marguerite
she's from Louisiana was she close she
was almost at almost full on Gilbert
great mom yeah Wow and so she gets
swapped out with so she's a very
Christian Jesus is the Lord blah blah
blah blah blah she gets swapped out with
a woman who is into like you know a
solstice party and like candles and
crystals and you know
New Age yeah and this woman comes back
and just nuts the house down she's like
I've never I've never seen so many dark
side of things in my life and she's
losing she started she searched all the
kids are like mom mom she's like did you
not pray for me I needed prayer and you
guys weren't there and they're like we
prayed for you she's like not enough I
want everybody out of my house in Jesus
name I pray if you believe in Jesus you
can stay here get the hell out of my
house in Jesus name I pray and she just
goes off she takes the check they give
him like X amount of thousands of
dollars just rips it up I don't want
anything tainted and darkness in my
house and the producers are like what
the [ __ ] and they're all losing their
[ __ ] and she's like she's like slacks
sly kicks not psychics it's like it's
Gargoyle slack excited all out of my
house and then at the end again it was
that uh what's the recap or whatever
they captured it's like after further
discussion she took the money bro let's
finish because I I love that on hoarders
uh uh hoarders was my [ __ ] so this is
what I was this is what it would get me
every time on hoarders you see the whole
story about they're trying to fix this
house you know and then the LAT the
recap is always like they lost the house
was condemned the worst thing you could
possibly think actually happened to
people yeah what this was like I don't
know why we love watching train wrecks
we love pot trashing train wrecks yeah I
love a good skeleton under a couch
oh no hoarders used to be terrible
because you'd be like you would look at
that should it be like could you look
around your own I look like I got [ __ ]
everywhere in my office and I just go oh
my god this is terrible
yeah but you're not collecting buckets
of your own feces can you imagine well
that's what's so weird it's like it just
becomes this thing where it's like I got
a I think that was a British version of
hoarders where this woman had to be like
it's the smells coming over to our house
Wow I mean Oh
that's like
or bug oh yeah when they got like oh I
like will they have like 15 cats and two
of them are dead yeah that's what I'm
saying the skeleton under the couch oh
yeah they're just they're like a skip
there's like there's a dead cat and she
can't figure out that you know you know
flippy has been dead for six weeks like
it's like to serve it to bring her back
and as I've I've had a cat before I know
the smell of having one cat yeah I
couldn't imagine well your senses are so
desensitized at that point because the
garbage in your refrigerator how does it
get to that point throwing [ __ ] in
there's always a hoarding for love say
they meet so there to meet online from
different countries to live in a hoarder
house or they get married and there's a
competition that is 20 of them so it's
like Big Brother right but they gotta be
hot because wouldn't it you know is it
never not like you never see Instagram
model hoarders right I would like to see
like if it was somebody that was super
hot and they were hoarding hoarding like
it it look different like I don't know
or is it always have to be somebody who
doesn't have that kind of life
ah that's the question out there yeah oh
then the question in the poll are
hoarders always yeah is there such a
thing as hot [ __ ] they're all hot
that's what I want to know yeah are
there hot hoarders out there that's well
no you know what
Justin we've been it's already been like
a bunch of time I can't believe we were
ranked you for this long you know what
is look at that you know I'm gonna have
you won again yeah what am i a people
we're gonna cuz I want you to catch up
on the shows and I'm gonna catch up on
the shells we'll give each other some
shells the next time we'll just recap
all these shows yes we do but you guys
you've heard me talk about servants so
many times so try to watch it it's good
I loves it but I'm scared watching some
of these train wrecks show you I can't
wait I'm a today fiance has like it's so
good that they have spin-off shows yeah
it's like 90 days not the 90 days after
there's like a da's beyond it's like
there's so many great couples and their
stories and it's like uh you know I have
to watch love is blind to because that's
the big one ever oh and then what's the
one on I have to watch the cake show
nailed it so good I do want to watch
love is blind to others blind nailed it
I have to watch succession and yes
people just shallow the last closing on
that I saw I was watching Steve Harvey
when his show was on and he had these
women on and he had these women they
were you know and it was almost like
dating game and there were three guys
they showed like through three women
three guys so the guy the women got to
choose by looking at them like ooh I
want him and it was all sexual
attraction uh-huh then they put the guys
behind the curtain and the woman got to
interview like just off voice like
interview and then they said now pick
who you want and it was all different ah
you know by personality is different
yeah you know so it's like and that's
the hard part is trying to find someone
that you are physically attracted to and
then someone you are emotionally
attracted to and you want that to be the
same thing and there's a lot of times
the pendulum is like you know 60/40
70/30 you have to figure out what that
is it's called dating in West Hollywood
it's cold
[Music]
and that shows coming to Netflix to
[Laughter]
people at home watch this but don't want
to you to treat record when I watch it
this is just against God let's find out
what it is up to Tristan and Elijah or
just add it again once trying to bake a
cake and the other one can't pick out
the right colors for the dress oh man
all right well this is just a Mario I'm
gonna have all your information but all
these information below look out for him
on your new show
March 11th on at 10:30 the funny dance
show right after Jade cata Preta and the
soup and now I'm having Jade on to
Jade's coming on too so my Jade from the
soup does it Justin from the dance
what's it called close enough the funny
dance show okay now we get we got to
work on the title no that's it that's we
tried to work put into a room haha oh
yeah multiple weeks multiple tests and
they came out with the funny dance was
there a discussion about that yes there
was because it was called stand up to
the streets and they're like it sounds
too much like stand up to cancer and
they were like no it doesn't and then
they were like let's like we'll just
call it the funny damn show cancer yeah
so they came up with the hilariously
creative the funny dance show so look
out for that the funny dance show that's
coming out hosted by you Justine Moreno
and Heidi he slit I'm I'm the judge I'm
the [ __ ] judge with Loni love and
Allison Holker anyway thanks for
watching we're from we grew up in and
like I say please subscribe and share
and I really appreciate you guys
watching every week and once again
Justin Martin thank you so much guys and
check here
[Music]